[Applaudissements]
le premier ministre justin trudeau a
présenté un nouveau cabinet avec une
part de stabilité par exemple richard
fuld aux finances bonsoir donc oui de la
continuité mais il ya aussi des
changements des postes clés parmi les
nominations remarquer l'ancien militant
de greenpeace steven guilbeault qui
obtient le ministère de l'environnement
mélanie joly devient la ministre des
affaires étrangères
la cinquième à occuper ce poste en six
ans ressources naturelles travailler
conseil du trésor tous changent de
titulaire parmi les nouveaux visages
notons pascal saintonge élus dans brome
missisquoi qui aura la responsabilité de
l' agence du développement économique
pour les régions du québec avec nous
pour faire le point sur les priorités du
gouvernement fédéral le ministre qui
reste aux commandes de l'innovation des
sciences et de l'industrie françois
philippe champagne bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur 10 ans plaisir d'être
avec vous ce soir beaucoup de
changements autour de la table du
conseil des ministres à laquelle on a
acheté plusieurs chaises on compte
maintenant 38 personnes 38 ministres
dont dix québécois vous êtes vous
heureux de préserver les mêmes
responsabilités
tout à fait me suis dit oh moi vous
savez j'ai déjà fait quatre ministères
en cinq ans quand le premier ministre du
canada m'a demandé de passer des
affaires étrangères à l'industrie qu'on
vous l'avais dit c'était pour justement
être le ministre de la relance
économique verte et le travail
s'accélère le travail continue alors
pour moi c'est une très bonne nouvelle
parce que vous savez on avait déjà
commencé à lancer des grands chantiers
vous l'avez vu par exemple au niveau de
la biofabrication on le fait dans
l'aérospatiale qui est un secteur clé a
bien évidemment chez inwi québec on le
fait dans le secteur de l'aluminium on
sera la première juridiction au monde à
produire d'aluminium vert on le fait
dans le secteur de l'acier on sera là
aussi canada le premier à produire de
l'acier vert et là évidemment mais la
vision qui s'en vient pour moi c'est au
niveau de l'industrie des batteries de
l'hydrogène il ya beaucoup de choses
monsieur dion qui vont nous permettre de
positionner comme je lé fais dans
l'aérospatiale quand je me suis
entretenu avec des dirigeants c'est à
dire comment on peut positionner
l'aérospatiale pour les 20 à 30
prochaines années c'est ce qu'on a
réussi à faire avec la propulsion
hybride les hélicoptères électrique par
exemple chez bell helicopter avec celle
ci alors on va faire le même genre de
travail pour positionner le québec le
canada de façon enviable parce
qu'aujourd'hui mais est ce que les gens
demandent qu'on peut concilier est ce
qu'on a appris à l'économie
l'environnement est-ce qu'on peut
présumer que toutes les annonces vont
passer par le prisme d'une analyse verte
notamment avec la nomination de steven
guilbeault ça envoie tout un message
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui à monsieur
zizian c'est ce que les consommateurs
exigent c'est ce que les marchés
financent et c'est certainement ce que
le gouvernement veut y met de l'avant
parce que les gens comprennent bien
aujourd'hui que on peut parfaitement
conjuguer l'emploi l'économie
l'environnement vous savez au québec on
en a fait la démonstration prenez les
lions électrique lenovo bus les taiwo
qu'ont annoncé 2 mars ambulance la
première ambulance électrique qu'on
annonçait récemment alors moi je pense
que le québec s'est taillé une place
enviable
le canada aussi vous savez on mois quand
les investisseurs m'appelle et me dit
monsieur champagne stabilité
prévisibilité les talents qu'on est chez
nous on est on s'est lancé dans
l'intelligence artificielle le cantique
moi je vous dis qu'aujourd'hui à
monsieur dion on a tout pour réussir
dans la nouvelle économie et c'est ce
qu'on voit c'est ce qu'on va mettre en
place pour accélérer les choses pour
être sûr qu'on puisse devenir un endroit
enviable on produit des choses dans
cette nouvelle économique et mais je
peux pas passer sous silence qu'ils
manquent de tout une des pénuries de
tout ça va de pis de pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre à la pénurie de semi
conducteurs vous vous êtes à
l'industriel quel va être votre rôle
là-dedans peau pour au moins stabiliser
la situation
bah écoutez ma voix c'est celle du monde
des enfers 7 des entrepreneurs des
petites moyennes entreprises vous avez
raison première en jeu c'est la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre et même durant la
campagne que j'en parlais c'est un enjeu
convient particulièrement dans nos
régions au québec mais à travers le pays
première chose on a dit qu'il y aurait
un crédit d'impôt pour les gens de 65
ans et plus qui veulent par choix rester
sur le marché du travail on ne parlait
aussi d'une allocation pour les gens qui
gagnent le salaire minimum mais qui ont
pas vraiment revenu de subsistance on a
parlé aussi évidemment des travailleurs
temporaires étrangers de l'immigration
pour ce qui est des semi conducteurs
monsieur dion j'étais chez ibm à bromont
chez nous au québec qui savait seule
usine au canada qui fait de l'assemblage
et la vérification des micros cheap des
semi conducteurs et j'ai parlé avec eux
évident manque d'avenir pour voir
comment on pouvait à contribuer c'est un
enjeu complexe en vous savez il ya une
compagnie dans le monde qui produit
environ 60% des semi conducteurs à
travers le monde mais clairement on est
en train de voir comment on peut
bonifier
l'approvisionnement chez nous parce que
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est un
enjeu important qui touche l'ensemble
des secteurs de l'industrie et on va
parler avec nos partenaires je serai à
washington la semaine prochaine pour
partager parler avec mon homologue
américaine la secrétaire du commerce et
on va se développer ensemble une vision
continentale comment on peut mieux faire
j'aimerais parler des vaccins production
de vaccins vous étiez tout juste avant
le déclenchement des élections avec le
pdg de moderna pour annoncer une usine
la construction d'une usine au canada
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce dossier
ça avance vous ne connaissez à monsieur
dion quand je lui parle quasiment toutes
les semaines on s'est parlé récemment on
échange et un savant c'est là la
compagne et à choisir le sait tous ici
ré où il mettrait l usine parce que vous
savez ces trois choses moderna d'abord
c'est un grand coup de circuit pour le
canada moderne qui choisit de venir
investir chez nous on parle d'une usine
de fabrication de vaccins mais on parle
aussi d'un centre d'excellence et d'un
centre de recherche alors les
discussions avancent et on sera en
mesure de faire une annonce vous désirez
prochainement des impôts mais la fée
moderne choisi l'année à jouer je dirais
que non ça va être plus rapide que ce
soit de 6 d'ici la fin de l'année
certainement parce que les dernières
conversations que j'ai eues c'est un
projet qui avance bien et qui est clé
parce que vous savez ça nous donne la
résilience une peu importe ce qui
arrivera moi je l'avais dit aux
canadiens et aux canadiennes on va
s'assurer de
rapatrier la fabrication chez nous on
voit les chaînes d'approvisionnement qui
était global qui devient comme
birégional plus d'en faire sur la
résilience que l'efficacité on va être
un joueur clé je peux vous dire en
domaine la biofabrication françois
philippe champagne merci beaucoup pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici r d